week actually if not a hard series let's
work with a little more
I even have space I'll just do it over
here what with the next term 8 2 5 8 11
and then 14 ok me good it for me good at
adding okay um what's gonna happen if I
only have two and 14 and I'm told I'm
told okay
this is 10 1 and this is term 5 as a
couple of interesting things to you for
starters if you know it's time 1 into 5
I don't just have one term to insert do
I have 1 2 3 okay now I can still get
the middle of those two terms that's
okay
this will still give me the middle does
that make sense do you see why because
if I forgot about 5 and 11 for a second
I'll still have an AP when I'm up to 814
it's just the gaps are why speak okay so
that's still works fine but then what
you have to do is you're gonna have to
insert them another pair of numbers to
divide that up a little more if you want
to think way back in statistics do you
remember there are these things called
quartiles
remember those interquartile range so
what you do is you've got like a set of
data right you had to find the middle
band what do we call the middle it's not
the mean it's called the median median
it's also known as q2 the second
quartile yeah if anyway anyway like
economics modes can like help me
seriously okay now then to get more
quartile quarters there's four of them
right you do this same process you find
the median here which gives you the
first quartile and then you do the
median here which gives you the Fed code
lab right and here is the interquartile
range right you've got a lowest number -
no but that'd be a term 1 to 10 5 that's
your that's the range there and you've
got how many nodes 1 2 3 4 5
what do we call this thing what do you
call this Phi Thomas oh no no it's the 5
point 4 5 number summary right it's what
you make a box and whisker plot Alice
like this and you don't like that okay
okay all right so all right let's let's
keep thinking so for instance suppose
now I have just that all right and you
get told
there's turn one and turn four how will
you work out I know that I've got to put
two intervening terms in one let's put
our thinking caps on how we're going to
do this what strategy can I use I've got
instead of the first answer I've got
first and fourth I've got to put in two
terms to make an AP okay so let me know
the way in terms of what I've already
got on the board okay remember when I
just had to an eight I said the first
thing we said was I have to add six to
get all the way there and that's two
steps adding six is two steps well if I
have a number that's further along the
chain by two to eleven he is adding how
much adding nine and how many steps is
that supposed to be it's supposed to be
three steps so you get your common
difference okay